i appreciate all the people that have
been supporting brittany on social media
i'm gonna say and reveal something i
took a different turn i've actually been
sending her personal videos you have i
have uh of encouragement and just
telling her that i think she is the key
to her freedom wow and i am very
invested in this i think everyone
deserves the chance to get their life
right wrong and everything in between
this has become
such public interest because it's about
something bigger it's about being
allowed to live your life and so i'm
invested in this and i really want her
to find her freedom has she answered
back have you heard back from her we get
little smoke signals i'm not gonna lie
all right but i told her you know i
think the thing that's important that i
felt to do for her was not go on social
media and say something quippy but to
really show her i'm someone who has
understood what a journey is like and i
don't compare myself to her but i'm here
to support her if there's anything she
needs in private we can date that's
beautiful
you